[Musik]
die frage die sich viele von euch in
diesen tagen stellen lautet wie stark
wird sich china aus dem fenster lehnen
um russland im krieg in der ukraine zu
unterstützen dies ist eines der größten
teil welches in diesem ganzen passen der
künftigen weltordnung noch fehlt china
ist nämlich die einzige supermacht
welche für die usa noch einen echten
rivalen darstellt und theoretisch würde
sich das gleichgewicht der kräfte
radikal verändern wenn peking moskau
entscheidend unterstützen würde
[Musik]
soweit die theorie aber ist dies auch
die realität in welchem umfang wäre
china bereit sich zu engagieren und
welche konsequenzen hätte dies um diese
frage zu beantworten muss man zunächst
eine andere frage beantworten was genau
denkt die chinesische regierung über die
invasion der ukraine nun an dieser
stelle wird alles ein bisschen
undurchsichtig und vor allem zwei
deutlich denn einerseits wiederholte
china schon einige zeit vor der
inversion botschaften wie die folgende
sie unterstützt auf gipfel putins
widerstand gegen die nato erweiterung
und unterstreicht die annäherung und in
den ersten stunden der invasion sackten
sie auch dinge wie diese wir haben
chinas grundsätzliche position zur
ukraine frage dargelegt es gibt einen
komplexen historischen hintergrund und
kontext in dieser frage russlands
verteidigungsministerium erklärte dass
seine streitkräfte keine raketen luft
oder artillerieangriffe auf städte
durchführen werden watching
stellvertretende außenministerien chinas
hier wird schon das alles sehr
kompliziert sei dass sie ja eh keine
zivilisten gefährden würden dass es sich
nur um eine begrenzte operation handeln
würde und so weiter und so fort bla bla
bla und während alle länder ihre sich
noch vor der invasion in der ukraine
finden bürger ausdrücklich banken das
land so schnell wie möglich zu verlassen
teilte die chinesische botschaft ihren
landsleuten in der ukraine ausdrücklich
mit sich sollten im land bleiben und
demonstrativ die chinesische flagge an
ihre feste hängen und auf ihre autos
montieren und mit ihnen die russischen
freier zu begrüßen scheinbar war die
führung der chinesischen kp umschrieb in
den gleichen blitzkrieg irrtum
aufgesessen die putin
[Musik]
tja so viel zur professionalität ihrer
geheimdienste und zur expertise ihrer
militär analysten vielleicht liegt es ja
daran dass in china youtube geblockt ist
und aus den stunden wurden tage aus den
tagen wochen und aus der blitzoperation
als vermögender vernichtungskrieg die
befreier kamen irgendwie nicht durch und
mit ihren offen zur schau gestellten
pro-russische chauvinismus zogen die in
der ukraine lebenden chinesen den hass
der ukraine auf sich denn sie beließen
es nicht bei den roten fahnen in
sozialen medien verbreiteten sie zum
beispiel auch hass botschaften und
schadenfreude gegenüber den ukrainischen
opfern in china selbst dagegen sich
sogar einige individuen in erniedrigen
den sex fantasien china soll jetzt
hübsche ukrainische flüchtlingsmädchen
als bräute importieren nach ein paar
tagen war das auch der chinesischen
botschaft profil sie empfahl ihren
bürgern lieber doch keine chinesischen
symbole und fahnen in der ukraine zu
zeigen und sind doch an ihre evakuierung
vorzubereiten dieses irrlichternde hin
und her mit ihrer fünften kolonne in der
ukraine symbolisiert das ganze
heuchlerische chaos in dem sich die
russland und ukraine politik pekings
befindet und so ging es dann auch weiter
zb im un sicherheitsrat
ukraine invasion china enthält sich bei
der abstimmung über die resolution des
un-sicherheitsrates zur verurteilung
russland es handelt sich hierbei um so
was wie jene peinliche stille die wie
ein donnerschlag wirkt nach den
anfänglichen statements über ihre
partnerschaft ohne grenzen muss chinas
stimmenthaltung für den kreml eine
ziemlich unangenehme überraschung
gewesen sein
[Musik]
als es darum ging wirklich vor der
ganzen welt farbe zu bekennen haben die
chinesen das nicht gekniffen der kreml
konnte sich nur auf die uneingeschränkte
unterstützung der art potente und
grenzenloser partner velaros syrien
nordkorea und eritrea verlassen was für
ein ehrenwerter club wer will da nicht
mitglied sein und das ganze stellte
schon einen ziemlichen dolchstoß da in
dieser vermeintlichen liebesgeschichte
die schiene bringen und wladimir putin
den letzten jahren gespielt haben nur
wenige staatsoberhäupter haben sich so
oft getroffen um euch eine vorstellung
davon zu geben die präsidenten russlands
und chinas wurden auf rund 40
gemeinsamen heißen dates gesichtet das
ist schon ein ziemlicher court putin hat
mir seine invasion extra bis zum ende
der olympischen spiele in peking
gewartet um den chinesen die party nicht
zu verderben eine party welche auch ohne
krieg ein ganz schöner flug bei wir
werden sie bald in einem richtig
deftigen video aufbereiten welches durch
den krieg nach hinten geschoben wurde
ihr dürft also schon gespannt sein aber
warum unterstützung ausland in diesen
krieg nicht stärker wird peking einen
vorteil aus dieser situation ziehen
wollen heute werden wir all diese fragen
natürlich beantworten es war womit genau
mit einem schnellen blick in die
geschichte zuvor würde ich aber gerne
ganz ganz lieb bitten auch dann als
spenden zu denken wenn wir es nicht in
jedem video ausdrücklich erwähnen ich
weiß es ist schwer aber unser aufwand
hält eben mit jedem video an egal ob wir
darin einen sponsor oder spendenaufruf
haben oder nicht die youtube
werbeeinnahmen sind zwar besser als auf
anderen plattformen aber kostendeckend
sind sie nicht daher diese kleine
erinnerung und natürlich großer dank an
alle die bereits gespendet haben und uns
vor allem regelmäßig unterstützen ihr
seid die besten dank euch können wir
weitermachen und so viele videos
veröffentlichen wie nie zuvor danke
danke und nochmals danke und nun weiter
im text und zurück in den kalten krieg
[Musik]
die perfekte zweckehe
es war die sowjetunion welche im
kommunistischen block während des
gesamten kalten krieges die
unbestrittene führungsrolle inne hatte
während der ersten jahre nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg hatte sie dabei auch
die unterstützung des
bevölkerungsreichsten landes der welt
mao tse tungs china ihre gemeinsame
berufung bestand darin den
kapitalistischen system des westens die
stirn zu bieten doch nach stalins tod
verschlechterten sich die beziehungen
zwischen moskau und peking
nach und nach wurden die streitigkeiten
zwischen chinesen und ins all dies immer
heftiger bis 1969 gar zu bewaffneten
zusammenstößen zwischen den truppen der
beiden länder entlang der grenze kamen
ihre gemeinsame grenze von mehr als 6000
kilometern war daraufhin die
jahrzehntelang stark militarisiert und
befestigt die udssr unterhielt dort bis
ende der 1980 er jahre 44 divisionen das
waren 13 divisionen mehr als an der
westfront gegen die nato nach dem
zusammenbruch der udssr verbesserten
sich die beziehungen zwischen russland
und china jedoch erheblich gemeinsam mit
anderen zentralasiatischen ländern
initiierten sie eine reihe von treffen
sie wurden als die chance bekannt und
ihr ziel war es die postsowjetischen
grenzen klar zu definieren was für die
verringerung der zahl stationärer
truppen unerlässlich war im laufe der
zeit wurden diese treffen in eine
internationale organisation umgewandelt
die shanghaier organisation für
zusammenarbeit kurz sz über die wir
bereits ein ganzes video gedreht haben
heute hat die sz ihre ziele erweitert
und ist teil der strategie chinas und
russlands eigene internationale
organisationen aufzubauen die mit denen
von den vereinigten staaten am ende des
zweiten weltkriegs geschaffenen
institutionen konkurrieren soll
tatsächlich haben china und russland
auch versucht ihre eigene alternative
zum stent system zu entwickeln da die
meisten russischen banken ist
mittlerweile nicht mehr nutzen können es
ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass sie zu
einem von china entwickelten system
wechseln werden tipps ist jedoch
lichtjahre vom klassischen swift
entfernt sie spielen noch nicht einmal
in der gleichen liga swift ist als
system das von mehr als 11.000
finanzinstituten in über 200
verschiedenen ländern genutzt wird
während nur 1200 institutionen im knapp
100 ländern das chinesische system
nutzen
über das chinesische system cifs können
die nicht nur zahlungen in eu an
verarbeitet werden welche noch nicht
einmal zwei prozent aller weltweiten
transaktionen ausmachen gegenüber 40
prozent in dollar waren nie dafür
gedacht swift zu ersetzen sondern ist
auf eine enge vernetzung mit ihnen
angewiesen außerdem gibt es viele
zweifel daran dass dieses system in
russland ohne probleme eingesetzt werden
kann das grenzüberschreitende renminbi
zahlungssysteme stützt sich immer noch
auf banken als knotenpunkte dies
funktioniert und beeinflusst werden
können die vereinigten staaten können
diese banken funktionieren change in
professor am shanghai advanced institute
of finance das jahr 2014 stellte einen
wendepunkt dar als der kreml die krim
annektierte straße der westen russland
mit sanktionen und seitdem hat putin
keine andere wahl mehr als sich mehr und
mehr im osten umzusehen apropos krim
china erkennt die russische alexion der
halbinsel auch bis heute noch nicht an
aber zurück zur wirtschaft
china scheint ja ein perfekter
handelspartners russland zu sein es
verfügt über technologie aber nicht über
viele natürliche ressourcen russland
hingegen hat viele ressourcen aber kaum
technologie die lösung scheint also
eindeutig zu sein und in der tat seit
2010 ist der handel zwischen moskau und
peking stetig gewachsen die zahl für
2021 sprechen für sich der chinesisch
russische handel erreicht ein rekordhoch
von über 140 milliarden us dollar china
ist nach der europäischen union zum
zweitgrößte exportmarkt für die
russische wirtschaft geworden und wenn
ich von russischer wirtschaftssprecher
ist klar worum es hier geht die hälfte
dessen was china von russland kauft ist
nichts anderes als rohöl es folgen kohle
erdgas und waffen bislang zumindest die
russen ihrerseits haben großes interesse
an chinesische technologie gezeigt und
mittlerweile haben sie ja auch gar keine
andere wahl mehr huawei wird zum
beispiel eine führende rolle bei der
entwicklung von ski in russland spiel
also falls es überhaupt kommen wird denn
russisches 5g bedeutet vor allem eins
zwei einkaufszentren und ein paar
megayachten vor zypern ich weiß wovon
ich spreche aber gut soweit der stand
der beziehungen zwischen diesen beiden
ländern zu zeitpunkt als putin sein
feuer sturm auf die ukraine losließ und
die frage ist wie genau hat peking
eigentlich auf den russischen angriff
reagiert nun um diese frage
zufriedenstellend beantworten zu können
müssen wir das ganze etwas genauer unter
die lupe nehmen
[Musik]
putins krieg
bei den letzten olympischen
winterspielen hat china die goldmedaille
in den teamwettbewerben gewonnen ich
versichere euch aber dass die
flexibilität der diplomaten des
asiatischen riesen derjenigen seiner
turner in nichts nachsteht diejenigen
von euch die visual politik regelmäßig
verfolgen haben sicher schon von der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz gehört sie
findet jedes jahr im februar statt und
interessehalber hat auch visuell politik
im jahr 2020 an dieser konferenz
teilgenommen aber das ist eine andere
geschichte interessanter ist heute eher
dass der chinesische außenminister war
per videokonferenz an der letzten
konferenz 2022 teilhaben im folgenden
clip seht ihr wie standhaft uns fest
seine position zur ukraine frage war als
er zu den spannungen an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze gefragt
wurde zur erinnerung zu diesem zeitpunkt
war es noch fünf tage bis zum 1
gut nicht wahr deutlicher hätte man es
eigentlich nicht ausdrücken können die
sache ist aber das ist doch ziemlich
leicht fällt einem so klaren standpunkt
zu vertreten wenn der status quo
erhalten bleibt und alles mehr oder
weniger ruhig ist aber wenn putin
plötzlich im fernsehen auftaucht und
sagt dass russische truppen kurz davor
sind die grenze zu überqueren dann
ändert sich die lage natürlich komplex
und da wird dass selbst der
aussenminister plötzlich zum
wackelpudding
als die invasion begann wurde die
chinesische regierung sehr unruhig als
ob sie plötzlich nach entschuldigungen
und rechtfertigungen für putins handeln
suchen müsste quasi nach dem motto wir
wissen dass ihr wisst dass wir es
wussten aber wir müssen so tun als
hätten wir nichts gewusst und wüssten
auch jetzt nicht als vierundzwanzigster
februar ist in version bereits in gange
war versuchte die sprecherin des
chinesischen außenministeriums yu jing
und sogar davon zu überzeugen dass der
krieg in der ukraine nicht einmal ein
krieg sei
es gibt einen komplexen historischen
hintergrund und kontext in dieser frage
russlands verteidigungsministerium
erklärte dass seine streitkräfte keine
raketen luft oder artillerieangriffe auf
städte durchführen werden
und der rest ist geschichte russland
ging nach dem gescheiterten blitzkrieg
für eine verbrecherische
vernichtungskrieg gegen die ukrainische
zivilbevölkerung über wir alle haben die
bürger vorne traf mario pohl und anderen
städten gesehen die von den russen
verwüstet wurden also begann china sich
langsam zu bewegen das problem war aber
dass china den un sicherheitsrat
angehört und als der un-sicherheitsrat
zusammenkamen um über den einmarsch in
der ukraine zu entscheiden hatte china
keine andere wahl als abzustimmen und
was glaubst du wofür china gestimmt
haben nun ist dasselbe getan wie bei der
alexander grimm es enthielt sich und
vermied es gleichzeitig putins
handlungen offen zu kritisieren
er setzt auf eine strategie die
doppelgänger nicht sein könnte peking
drückt im eigenen land knallharte
dasselbe narrativ über den ukraine krieg
durch dass auch moskau herbei liegt es
handle sich nur um eine spezialoperation
zur entnazifizierung der ukraine
interessanterweise berichten zwei und
ausland publizieren chinesische
staatsmedien aber durchaus auch über
kriegsverbrechen der russen nur eben
nicht in china selbst und der
chinesische vertreter bei den vereinten
nationen schon beschuldigte die nato die
ursache aller probleme zu sein jene
abgedroschen ausrede dass an aggression
alle anderen schuld tragen nur nicht der
aggressor selber
noch viel weniger kann die regionale
sicherheit durch die stärkung der gruppe
und damit durch eine erweiterung der
gruppe vor dem hintergrund von fünf
aufeinander folgenden runden der
nato-erweiterung gewährleistet und die
legitimen sicherheitsbestimmungen
russlands sollten beachtet und
angemessen berücksichtigt
es ist diese klassische meese täter
opfer umkehr nach dem motto sie ist
selbst daran schuld vergewaltigt worden
zu sein sie hätte ja keinen mini rock
anziehen brauchen und diese taktik ist
ebenso verwerflich wie aalglatt denn
eine klare unterstützung von moskau
stellt sie auch nicht dar denn
andererseits behauptet peking auch dass
es ihr eigentlich gar nicht gefalle was
in der ukraine so vor sich gehen würde
eigentlich müsste das land ja seine
territoriale integrität verteidigen und
außerdem sollte man diese ganze
unangenehme situationen doch am besten
im gemeinsamen dialog lösen die
chinesische pseudo kommunisten versuchen
also tatsächlich sich irgendwie sowohl
auf die seite des angreifers als auch
auf die des angegriffenen zu stellen
peking versucht quasi einen ganz neuen
benchmark für das phänomen der nicht
interpretierbar kai zu setzen am
liebsten würden die chinesischen
diplomaten wohl in die annalen der
physik eingehen und sowohl die
heisenbergsche unschärferelation als
auch schrödingers katze komplett in den
schatten stellen man kann ja eigentlich
schon betten schließen an welchem tag
ticking welche version seiner
schizophrenen position öffentlich
präsentieren wird wenn der russische
außenminister lavrov zu besuch kommt
betont mal die unendlichkeit der
gemeinsamen freundschaft und des
chinesisch russische strebens nach
frieden und unabhängigkeit von der us
hegemonie und wenn ein gipfel mit der eu
entsteht zeigt man sich angeekelt vor
der schrecklichen gewalt die in der
ukraine irgendwie passiere und auch
davon dass hier die integrität eines
souveränen staates auf gröbste weise
verlässt wird die chinesen wollen von
allen gewaschen werden ohne auch nur
einen tropfen wasser abzubekommen ihr
ziel ist es die ultimative profiteure
dieses ganzen konflikt zu werden ihr
problem ist nur sie wissen eigentlich
noch gar nicht wie es hier scheint
nichts als ein frommer wunsch zu sein
sie haben den piraten putin erst mal
einen geheimen körper brief für die
ukraine aus gestellt in der hoffnung
russland würde die ganze drecksarbeit
für china übernehmen und die ganze
rechnung dafür bezahlen während china
selbst weiterhin nur die profite ab
greift das ist fast schon so genial wie
die masche der systemrelevanten banken
während der finanzkrise profite werden
privatisiert und verluste sozialisiert
in diesem fall haltlos ifi ziert
allerdings ist diese strategie ebenso
durchsichtig wie fragwürdig wenn man
überhaupt von einer strategie reden kann
[Musik]
in peking scheint man eher so hoffen die
dinge würden sich schon irgendwie zu den
eigenen gunsten fügen wenn man das ganze
nur lange genug aussetzen würde man
fährt auf sicht und gibt vor sich
eigentlich gar nicht so sehr um den
ausgang des krieges zu kümmern dieser
krieg sei putin krieg und man will
wieder dabei noch nicht dabei sein die
chinesen werden weder für russland noch
für die ukraine ihre brücken abbrechen
denn dies können sie sich auch gar nicht
leisten sie haben schon genug probleme
mit der immobilienkrise den
wirtschaftsaufschwung und ihren eigenen
auslandsbeziehungen ein weiteres chaos
biopolitischen ausmaß ist könnte sich
als recht fatal erweisen denn china
hatte diesen krieg durchaus vieles zu
verlieren schließlich wissen wir alle
was chinas hauptziel ist erst recht
nachdem wir gesehen haben was im januar
letzten jahres passiert ist und was sich
in den letzten monaten wiederholt china
schickt die seit oktober größte zahl von
kampfflugzeugen in die verteidigungszone
taiwans tatsächlich fragen sich viele
analysten optischen ping nicht daran
dachte putin schon mal als mini spüre
und vorzuschicken damit dieser mal die
der fähigkeit des westens austestet und
dann seinen blitzkrieg zu imitieren um
in taiwan einzufallen natürlich am
besten mit sehr unterschiedlichen
situationen zu tun die ukraine ist ein
souveränes und international anerkanntes
land im gegensatz dazu wird taiwan von
fast keinem land als eigenständiger
staat anerkannt nicht einmal offiziell
von den usa auch wenn diese sich zu
seiner verteidigung verpflichtet haben
was zur beiden erst kürzlich unterstrich
wir haben über diese problematik und
wurden schon einige videos gedreht ich
wäre sie euch in der beschreibung
verlinken und die politik putins die
souveränität der ukraine in frage zu
stellen richtet sich im grunde gegen
pekings eigene doktrin da es andere
nationen darin bestärken würde chinas
anspruch auf teil waren in frage zu
stellen ein konzept dass peking so gerne
verteidigt der massive widerstand der
ukraine das scheitern des blitz kriegs
und die reaktion des westens und der
weltöffentlichkeit auf putins
aggressionen haben peking jedoch klar
gemacht dass dies nicht im moment ist
aber sie schauen genau hin und lernen
aus dem krieg sie beobachten zb welche
waffen der besten bereit ist einzusetzen
um eine atomar bewaffnete macht zu
stoppen
[Applaus]
außerdem deutet alles darauf hin dass
der widerstand der usa im falle einer
invasion teil war es noch größer wäre
taiwan ist erneut größter handelspartner
der usa und ein halbleiter supermacht
außerdem deren hypothetische sanktion
zur einschränkung des handels mit dem
westen tödlich für die chinesische
wirtschaft wie sowohl in vielen
strategischen sektoren noch immer von
importen aus dem westen als auch
finanziell komplett von denen von dort
fließt den exporteinnahmen abhängig ist
ein zusammenbruch des handels zwischen
china den usa europa japan südkorea und
australien wurde nicht nur zum kollaps
der chinesischen wirtschaft führen
sondern auch zu massiven sozialen
verwerfungen und unruhen dies alles
führt uns zu einer wichtigen überlegung
die sanktions batterie mit der die
alliierten moskau wirtschaftlich
bombardieren könnte über militärische
interessen hinaus gehende folgen für die
welt und insbesondere für die chinesen
selbst haben wenn die neuen kriege der
zukunft nicht mehr auf dem schlachtfeld
ausgetragen werden ist es vielleicht
nicht mehr so wichtig immer mehr und
mehr in die streitkräfte investieren um
die stärkste aller armeen zu haben es
sei denn du hast eine gemeinsame grenze
mit putin aber darum geht es nicht um
gegen die russische armee zu bestehen
braucht man nicht das größte militär der
welt viel mehr brodelt in der
chinesischen gesellschaft nun eine
hitzige debatte sowohl in fachkreisen
als auch am stammtisch der in china die
parkbank ist und in dieser debatte geht
es nicht nur darum ob es klug war einen
verlierer wie putin zu einem kriegs
proxy chinas zu machen und ob man putin
weiter unterstützen solle sondern auch
um die frage kann ich ihn angesichts der
militärischen verhältnisse die nur ans
licht gekommen sind überhaupt noch ein
wettrüsten mit den usa gewinnen wird es
dadurch nicht in diese falle tappen wie
einst die sowjetunion die chinesen sind
nämlich sehr pragmatisch und
anpassungsfähig und die welt sieht heute
eben doch wieder etwas anders aus als
jener zeit als die meisten die ukraine
könnte der mächtigen russischen armada
keine zwei tage standhalten also fängt
das reich der mitte nun an darüber
nachzudenken wie es auch diese nun
entstandene situation ausnutzen könnte
wie könnte es maximal davon profitieren
dass putin seinem eigenen land in den
fuß geschossen hat
die beute des strandpiraten china
[Musik]
eine der wichtigsten sanktionen die
gegen russland verhängt wurden betrifft
die russische zentralbank und das
einfrieren ihrer devisenreserven bei
dieser gelegenheit könnte china eine
wichtige lektion gelernt haben eine
lektion die peking helfen wird in
zukunft eine so harte strafe die in
russland zu entgehen immerhin ist china
das land mit den größten devisenreserven
der welt wir reden hier über einen
gegenwert von etwa 3200 20 milliarden us
dollar und in diesem fall ist es
wirklich der us dollar der in chinas
reserven die dominante währung darstellt
die regierungschefin hat sich sehr
kritisch über die sanktionen gegen
russland geäußert und hat keinen grund
sich selbst zu übernehmen oder
anzuwenden zumindest wird sie aber sehr
vorsichtig sein das war sie eine
entscheidung tritt die ihren zugang zum
internationalen finanzsystem gefährden
würde ein vorgeschmack darauf haben sie
bereits bekommen als die usa einige
führende politiker in hongkong mit
sanktionen belegt haben und was den
handel angeht so ist dies eine
gigantische und komplexe geschichte für
sich die sich ein eigenes video verdient
hätte klar ist nämlich auch wenn chinas
handel mit russland wächst ist im
vergleich zu den mit den usa der eu
japan taiwan südkorea australien
verschwindend klein besprechen noch
nicht einmal von einem 25
nur eine kleine ausschlag im handel mit
dem westen hätte für chinas wirtschaft
wesentlich bedeutender konsequenzen als
ganz russland was könnte china also von
russland im gegenzug für seine
unterstützung wollen nun und wenn wir
darüber nachdenken müssen es dinge seien
bei den peking wirklich viel zu gewinnen
hat denn heutzutage ist es ziemlich
verpönt und gerade zu riskant mit
russland geschäfte zu machen es muss
also schon etwas verdammt lukratives
geht etwas wovon china überproportional
profitiert auf kosten russlands
natürlich
[Musik]
ein sektor in china große sorgen
bereitet ist zum beispiel die
ernährungssicherheit vor dem krieg waren
die weltmarktpreise für lebensmittel
bereits auf dem höchsten stand seit zehn
jahren und nun weisen experten darauf
hin dass der krieg in der ukraine die
weltweite weißen versorgung bedrohen
könnte china hat beschränkungen für
russische weisen importe auf ja genau
bisher hat peking die russischen weizen
importe stark limitiert das soll sich
nun ändern man kann ja nicht jeden tag
nur eis essen und dann wäre da natürlich
noch das erdgas chinas erdgas verbraucht
hat sich in den letzten zehn jahren
verdreifacht und da die heimische
produktion gerade mal 60 prozent des
aktuellen bedarfs deckt muss der rest
importiert werden das meiste davon kommt
als verflüssigtes erdgas lng nach china
das problem mit energie ist dass es
deutlich teurer ist als pipelinegas und
russland china per pipeline derzeit nur
etwa 15 prozent seiner erdgasimporte
anbieten kann größer sind die
kapazitäten einfach nicht das was sich
natürlich in den nächsten jahren ändern
[Musik]
im jahr 2009 10 wurde liegt power of
sight b real gas pipeline in betrieb
genommen die 2025 ihre volle kapazität
erreichen wird außerdem wurde beim
letzten treffen zwischen putin und
schießen bringen eine zusätzliche
vereinbarung mit lieferung von gas über
eine neue rote getroffen und selbst die
invasion der ukraine hat diese pläne
vorerst nicht unterbrochen das pläne den
weg für neue gasgeschäfte mit china
während russland von sanktionen
betroffen ist die rede ist von der story
rostock megal-pipeline wenn diese drei
projekte fertiggestellt sind wird sich
die russische exportkapazität nach china
vervielfachen das würde die chinesischen
importe billiger machen und die
versorgungssicherheit erhöhen aber damit
keine illusionen aufkommen auch dann
wird china in europäischen gasmarkt für
russland hin nicht ersetzen können
deswegen wird china angesichts
verstärkter isolation russland
sicherlich in der lage sein dem kreml
die günstigsten bedingungen abzubringen
die gegen russland verhängten sanktionen
lassen uns sogar die möglichkeit in
betracht ziehen dass die beziehungen
zwischen peking und moskau noch und
ausgewogener werden unter kreml sehr
abhängig von seinen geschäften mit china
wird und dann wird es für das regime von
jean ping an der zeit sein eine seiner
spezialitäten in die praxis umzusetzen
pekings sugardaddy diplomatie
[Musik]
was sugar der die diplomatie ist nun das
haben wir euch bereits in früheren
ressort politik videos erklärt und ich
werde sie euch natürlich verlinken china
wird diese taktik anwenden weil
russlands position des so stark
geschwächt ist dass es einen punkt
erreicht an dem der chinesischen schule
der die anfängt dinge zu verlangen und
angebote zu machen die russland einfach
nicht mehr ablehnen kann es braucht also
einfach nur lange genug zu warten bis
putins reich so richtig ausgeblutet ist
und einfach keine andere wahl mehr hat
der stand bei razzien hat putin durch
seine leuchtfeuer an die ukrainische
klippe geführt und wartet nun darauf das
strandgut deshalb ihr zerschellen den
russischen kriegsschiffs einsammeln zu
können wie er dies bewerkstelligen will
und wie man ihn daran hindern könnte nun
dies wird das thema eines eigenen videos
auf jeden fall stellt sich die frage ob
china schlecker kurs nicht einfach viel
damit zu tun hat dass es gar nicht in
seinem interesse wäre der russischen
wirtschaft wirklich aus der patsche zu
helfen je länger man es in seinem selbst
entfachten inferno zappeln lässt desto
billiger werden die einkaufspreise für
die rohstoffe oder gar gleich ganze
vorkommen und kunst herne ist also bitte
nicht das abo mit glücklichen denn in
einem der nächsten videos hier auf
dieser politik werden wir diese
problematik im detail unter die lupe
nehmen und glaubt mir dabei wird so
manche überraschende tatsache und
wendung ans licht kommen aber jetzt seid
ihr erstmal mit eurer meinung an der
reihe welche rolle sollte shipping euro
ansicht nach in ukraine trick spielen
glaubt ihr dass china jemals eine
eindeutige position einnehmen wird wie
immer sind sie auch eure meinung in den
kommentaren schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt habt gebt uns bitte einen
leitpfosten euren freunden und vergesst
nicht dass aber mit glöckchen um keines
unserer videos mehr so verpassen
natürlich wollen wir auch jederzeit über
eine spende von regus hält dieses
projekt weiterzuführen in paper link
dazu findet ihr beschreibung unter dem
video macht es gut und ist bald
[Musik]